[Music]
okay I just got done seeing detective
Pikachu yes which you know it's an atom
it's an animated movie I guess well not
really it was life actual live actually
makes him put a bunch of stuff in it
maybe you explain third me it's it's a
video game movie you know video game
movies just tend to be [ __ ] but this one
I would say it's probably one of the
better video game movies that turned up
terms of production and the quality of
the movie and the acting was you know
pretty good I didn't actually like the
movie myself really I thought the tone
was just all over the place but I got a
feeling that most people that are in a
Pikachu type video games have loved the
movie probably so you know I'm not
really attended audience what do you
make of it eh yeah it's like it wasn't
bad but I'm not like I'm not a huge like
Pokemon fan so it's like you know I knew
enough about it that you know I could
follow the story and I mean for like
what's a bit of character of powers war
and stuff like that so I wasn't likely
later you know it did kind of come
completely out of left field or anything
like that sort of know what's going on
and I kind of liked the way they did
kind of like it was you know it was like
a mystery story so it was that they had
like a little bit of a noir thing going
on I have to say probably the best thing
I mean easily the best thing about it
was Ryan Reynolds
Pikachu so you know and he kind of shows
up at the end as well because there's
like a whole thing I don't like spoiling
kids who anybody wants to see it but
it's based on you know not only based on
Pokemon is it as a whole but it was
based on a particular video game called
detective Pikachu so I'm not sure I've
never played the game so I don't know
hopefully the story is to think that it
has to do with the scientist and he has
like invented some gas that like makes
all the pitching like flip out or like
get lazy or whatever then he's tried and
then there's like the scientists that
like trying to I guess he's trying to
like put them together somehow or liked
it is doing there's a lot of stuff about
it that doesn't make any sense and a lot
of stuff was just kind of never really
resolved about you know giant turtles
and [ __ ] like that for me that the big
problem at the movies it fielded the
movie to me is obviously blade Blade
Runner
prometheus and aliens it's it's that
universe but then the peach of Pikachu
thing is kind of forced into this movie
to make it a Pikachu movie I mean
instead of aliens and instead of
replicants and instead of you know
engineers you got these take it to
things but just this would have been a
pretty serious sci-fi adventure if if it
wasn't about Pikachu's it's kind of like
they forced that into pokemons or
Pokemon there's more than is this [ __ ]
you know I mean they're [ __ ] funny
but they all yeah he was one of those
main people to call Pokemon see yeah I
know a pocket monster to me is something
you know I'm carrying around a [ __ ]
block in Boston you know it's uh yeah I
don't give [ __ ] about it it's just it
looks like they had a science fiction
movie that was modified into yeah
and I'm not sure if this is the case but
I just totally but yeah like a script
that was originally something else but
like I said since it was based on a
specific video I enjoyed it but it's not
you know it's Pokemon as like I said
isn't my thing I don't know a huge
amount about it I do enough about it to
follow along with the story you know and
Ryan Reynolds was funny
he's always funny I liked him so you
know it's it could have been better
could've been worse so I'm sure a lot of
people are here in a Pokemon you gotta
love this [ __ ] if you don't give a [ __ ]
about Pokemon do this good this is just
gonna be a piece of [ __ ] yeah it seems
just cute pretty young I would be like I
mean I'm sure like maybe like it's kind
of hard year Tori I was just going come
on like yeah yes I'm not the intended
target yet heartiest Tom's gonna [ __ ]
off I'm gonna go hang out with with the
Pikachu
[Laughter]
you
okay we just got done see end of you
dull ugly dolls are ugly dolls dougla
dolls
yeah animated movie animation was pretty
good it all looked like fabric and that
was super cool yeah it was a music it
was a musical - head catchy tunes yeah
yeah what I couldn't do this a lot of
kind of famous singers Kelly Clarkson
the theme of this one is about
appearances you know two separate sets
of dolls inside of the doll factory when
I'm more of a doll Zoo like little
perfect dolls and the theme is about
appearance you know and then it's all
kind of resolved and that the purpose of
the doll of purpose of a dolls to have
love and compassion and they got all got
along and a hand it's still kids
feel-good story there's a little kid in
the audio there's little kids in the
audience but if they were just loving it
it's not really for us but I tolerated
it I liked it a lot better than the
Pikachu movie I actually did - I thought
this was quite adorable noxious yeah
like the songs are really cute the
animation was really cool like I really
enjoyed like looking at all the details
especially how it all looked like
tactile yeah good stuff um the songs
especially the little villain songs that
Nick Jonas did will be very very funny
and I do like those and I like the way
it was shot like with all scary shadows
and [ __ ] like that yeah these are based
on I remember the ugly doll is coming
out the toys I've ever been the 90s Oh
I remember seeing that's maybe a hot
topic or something like that and I
always thought they were super cute so
but yeah this is kind of a thing where
the ugly dolls you know they they live
in this little village where they don't
know but they find out later that they
were the rejects from the doll factory
because they had like
you know Selvam only had one eye or
there was like the fucked-up [ __ ] on
their head or whatever so they kind of
got kicked off to some other place but
they didn't know that at the time so
they were super happy but then when they
find out that all the dolls are suppose
to be perfect and are supposed to be
pretty and stuff then they kind of get
all bummed out about it but there's like
it's kind of like a cool little message
and all if you got other kids you can
take it to I do
you know the [ __ ] these movies are
not for us and they're definitely not
for me we're not the intended market and
in the same way that there are four kids
the idea of these things is from an
adult perspective can you take a kid to
go see it with the kid enjoy it and will
it or will it and will it try if you
[ __ ] crazy or not yeah if it drives
you [ __ ] crazy it's a fit like I said
I thought super cute not even hands yeah
this was similar theme to Toy Story yeah
and this one didn't ride me crazy was
enjoyable I could kind of zone out and
just enjoy it yeah whatever not try to
think too much about it and you know I
mean you'd be able to take a kid to it
and it wouldn't drive you [ __ ] crazy
so yeah I think I liked it better than
the movie as well I didn't mind the
Pikachu movie as much as you did I
didn't like it but it does feel like
yeah it's pretty even a younger audience
but like I said I also kind of zoned out
during parts of you know just oh yeah I
mean it just when it comes to little
kids movies like that I'm just my quote
for me is for the question for me is is
this [ __ ] driving me crazy
yeah and if it's not annoying me then
I'm happy yeah because I wouldn't go see
this on my own I'd normally go if I had
to take again yeah if I had a kid or and
honestly I think the kids are probably
like kids real of it is it's awesome
looking I really really liked the whole
look of it in the whole you know
aesthetic of it was
cool and the songs were cute like the
characters were cute I just thought it
was cute yeah yeah
okay yeah John wick three Parabellum if
you've seen John wick one and two you
won't be disappointed as [ __ ] suck
your bad ass it's just more the same
it's like the other ones I'd probably
put it on par with well it's hard it's
hard to put one above another one I
think I think all the movies are pretty
much equally good yeah but now if you
like we wanted to it it [ __ ] delivers
I mean you know [ __ ] ridiculous
[ __ ] gun kung fu and gun porn it's
[ __ ] awesome you know it's just it
was like it was just like one or two
cool locations cool outfits product
placement and [ __ ] looking high quality
watches and motorcycles and just nothing
to complain about it I mean I really
liked they had some like really good
gore in this yeah yeah I think probably
my favorite I mean because there was
this is pretty much I mean just like one
and two it's pretty much like just one
long fight scene yeah it's not much
talking in it kind of like Mad Max fury
road just to show and not you've seen
one and two it's like I think this one
starts what like an hour after the
second one yeah it's right when they
declare him this means that everyone
yeah pretty much in the world that's
associated with the high table you know
is out to get him
it's like a 14 million dollar bounty of
which is later up to 15 million dollar
bounty super so pretty much you can't go
anywhere without like every other [ __ ]
like trying rose and but yeah I really
like that the one knife fight with like
we're here Thurid that was really yeah
like the one of the first night the
whole thing is just one big long mafia
fantasy yeah you know mafia yeah
yes the tones just right I mean you
can't you can't
this can be violent it could be exciting
and you can't take this real seriously I
mean this [ __ ] that they're doing it's
just that isn't the way that isn't the
way gun fights are it's just just and go
that way but it looks [ __ ] cool on
camera the movies about style style and
fun yeah movie packed actually we're
gonna see the earlier one but it was
full plenty of [ __ ] like gangster
rituals that they have to do and just
just [ __ ] that's it it's it's it's
imagine if a mafia hitman movie was a
cartoon or a comic book that's what it's
like yeah but it's real stylish this
[ __ ] oh yeah and this is not the end of
course they set it right up for for yeah
so they're good because like the end I
was like all right nothing there's
awesome is this all all old dudes doing
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dudes in their
40s and 50s doing [ __ ] kung fu and
you're like in there like really doing
it it looks like it yeah kick it over
their heads and [ __ ] you know [ __ ] I
like Kenny Reeves he's all right I mean
it he's pretty cool and he's he's
perfect for this role I mean he still
runs like a [ __ ] surfer boy though he
runs [ __ ] funny
yeah road sucks I'm out of Bill and
Ted's man you've got that same run runs
like he's joking although that's better
than Steven Seagal's Rob's did Steven
Seagal runs like a [ __ ] flaps his arms
like bunch of chicken wings and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
so Reeves doesn't run like a [ __ ]
though he just runs like surfer you've
been smoking a joint hey man hey yeah
he's big yeah it's cool let's go mama
hey yeah
yeah I've liked all the time work maybe
yeah and you know if you like the first
two I don't see why you wouldn't like
this one yeah I got a I got a I got a
feel this is gonna be the best movie of
the month for me I mean you know my
opinion
oh I should say that before this one we
saw the first for the first time we saw
the trailer yeah the new hit that looks
good yeah yeah and that looks really
good yeah
all right we got it's late we gotta go
[Music]